hello everyone I hope we're all having a
great Sunday and I know some of you
might be thinking dude why are you
showing us a bullet game well the reason
is this bullet game has far less
mistakes than a lot of classical games I
show you the reason is it's played
between world champion Magnus Carlsen
and Grand Master Andrew Tang who is a
well all-around famous on the Internet
he plays he plays so fast that like
Peter Pan they say he moves faster than
his shadow and this is from the first
title event on LI chess it was the it
was a bullet tournament held for titled
players and probably everyone thought
that penguin I am one also known as
Andrew Tang would win this tournament
but in the end he got third place first
place went to Grandmaster Danny the
donkey who was actually magnus carlsen
although at the time tournament was
played and the one actually knew it was
magnus carlsen and the second place
wants to I use a username called Bombay
Baron not a who I have no idea who he is
a lot of players were saying that that's
actually Fabiano Caruana
but if anyone knows do share in the
comments so let's let's see this game we
had efore and each six Andrew goes for
the for the French defense d4 d5 and E
captor son d5 cross and goes for the
exchange of variation of the French and
I know a lot of you heard Michael Tao
saying that the exchange variation of
the French when you're playing with the
white pieces is a crime against chess
but then again I'm sure you all know the
famous sentiment by John Lilly in his
you feeis all is fair in love and war
I would I would extend this to all in
fair all is fair in love war and the
bullet because at these time controls
you know anything goes he kept her son
d5 and Bishop to d3 so Knight to f6
Knight to f3 Bishop to d6 cross and
castles tanked castles and c4 we had h6
c5 Bishop to e7 now and Knight to c3
Knight to c6 Bishop to b5 Bishop to d7
now
one a six kicking the bishop away cousin
captures tank captures and now Knight to
e5 and Bishop back to thee seven now we
have Queen to f3 and Bishop to e6 and
this is a beautiful setup for Carlsen
the knight on e5 and the d4 c5 pawn it's
very tricky why black can never really
destroy this pawn center if he pushes a
b6 at any point you will get c6 and then
this pawn and c6 will be will be a
monster
so Bishop clear for by Carlsen rook to
e8 and rook to e3 now Carlson is
preparing to double up on the e-file
Bishop to f8 rook 81 now Carlsen doubles
up and worked a queen to ca and till
this position I mean until this move
move 17 it was actually pretty I mean it
was a pretty much a perfect game played
there were no no inaccuracies on either
sides and here Andrew goes for the first
in accuracy he plays Queen to c8 a
better move was queen it was g5 but
after Queen to c8 he allows Carlsen to
capture the h6 pawn would idea of Bishop
captures now if you capture back you
lose the knight on f6 so this would
require some calculation which isn't
really something you want to go forward
when playing a bullet game after Knight
to g4 now Knight captures Bishop
captures now your Bishop and queen are
attacked but after Queen to g3 simply
rook captures and Bishop captures rook
Bishop e6 and you end up being up upon
now this might find you know seemed
funny to you dude why would you you know
risk so much time calculating
being up upon in a bullet game but these
guys are so good at the D stand controls
that up on up is actually probably
winning the game but after Queen to c8
Carson doesn't go for this
he goes for h3 and he has planned c6 now
and like I said it's very hard to
develop for black if you push b6 trying
to destroy white century simply get c6
and this pawn is controlling the entire
Queen side you're you're gonna have a
terrible time playing this especially at
low time controls
so after h3 c6 was played but now
to a for now tangle out cousin to bring
his night to be six and there's really
nothing you can do about this
Queen to d8 not allowing 96 would
attempt on the Queen and the rook but
nice to be a b6 all the same rook to b8
and now Knight the d3 opening up a
discovered attack from the bishop on f4
and there is no way to save the rook
here so rook to e8 and now Carlsen
although it's bullet very low time
controls one minute per player Bishop to
e5 improving the position
there's no rush to capture that rook
Knight to d7 and Knight captures an a8
Queen captures on a 8th and 9th to f4
now Bishop to a5 Bishop to d6 now
opening up an attack towards the rook on
e8 Bishop to e4 blocking this Queen to
g3 and Knight back to f6 Bishop - sorry
f3 kicking the bishop bishop to h7 and
now rook captures Knight captures and we
have Bishop captures on f8 key factors
and night to h5 here what white is
simply winning cost and it's threatening
the capture on g7 of course the rook is
attacking the knight on e 8 which is
defending the g7 pawn so the threat is
rook captures and then capturing and g7
and here tank played Queen to d8 he
allowed such a tactic but it doesn't it
doesn't really help if you play
something like Bishop to g6 simply Queen
to h4 now you can't capture the night
Queen to d7 is a threat if you capture
27 King goes capture capture capture and
after King h7 rook b8 you're losing all
of these bonds the bishop is too far
away to protect any of the pawns so
after Knight h5 tank played Queen to d8
and here we have rook captures with
check King captures and now Queen
captures on g7 Bishop to Bishop to g6 as
the bishop was attacked on h7 now Knight
to f6 check King e7 and now a beautiful
move by Carlsen aka Danny the donkey pin
captures on h6 you can't capture the
knight of course if you capture it Queen
h4
when the twins black queen so after
Queen h6 Queen to a5 but now comes Queen
III check King B 8 a 3 between b5
attacking the b2 upon b4 and Queen the
Queen to see for King 2 h2 not allowing
any Queen drops with check like Queen f1
although it wouldn't really really help
black and here after King h2 black
doesn't really have a move any move he
makes loses the game terribly for
example you can't run away with the King
or something like that if King c7 then
Queen e7 King bee 897 check King gate 7
Queen b6 threatening Queen b8 checkmate
there is no way to threaten white king
he's very safe on h2 a5 maybe a check
King e6 Queen a checking b5 Queen
captures on a5 this is checkmate
so after King h2 tank try to f5 at least
maybe trying to protect the d7 square to
avoid some checks but simply Queen to a
check King to c7 and now Queen - Queen
to e5 check checking the King and
attacking the bishop on f5 and
disposition penguin I am 1 or enter tank
resigned the game you can't really do
anything here if you play King c8 you
lose the bishop with tempo if you try
King b8 then you're simply getting
checkmated Queen checks bishop covers
Queen here check King has nowhere to go
Bishop has to walk and Queen captures on
d7 this is checkmate so although it was
a bullet game I mean it's incredibly
precise how these players play at such
low time controls I remember last year
in December when when I was watching the
finals of the speech Chess Championship
and chess calm cousin was playing
against Nakamura and okay you have three
time controls in that match and when
they reached the bullet section I
thought I thought man now Nakamura is
gonna mop the floor with Carlsen but
that was not nearly the case you know
Carlsen really destroyed him in every
segment I don't think if he destroyed
him in bullet but
I don't think Nakamura had any any upper
hand there so I really thought that I
mean especially against Andrew tang who
is like so fast I often watch his games
and it doesn't matter what he plays if
he plays bullet hyper bullet Ultra
bullet he always goes berserk and going
berserk at Ultra bullet Ultra bullet is
like 15 seconds per player and then you
go berserk you get seven and a half
seconds and he actually plays a decent
game in these seven and a half seconds
so it's it's quite amazing how Coulson
can you know Rumble with with these guys
at these time controls you know
obviously time control doesn't matter if
you're a good player you're a good
player in any time control so yeah
that's the game I would like to thank
Stephen Turing sanski marked with
Rayleigh and algebra 33 for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
I think y'all for watching and I will
see you soon and I forgot to mention
cause someone $500 for winning this
tournament and he donated those $500 to
leeches to add to the price for the next
titled event so yeah thank you for
watching and I will see you soon